[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants bonsoir bonsoir je
connais un nouveau jeu ce qu'on va
s'amuser je peux y aller
patron bien sûr nounours tu es tellement
pressé d'aller jouer à l'on amuse toi
bien mais ne triche pas soyez
tranquilles bon lol voilà qui hanta
cigale à s'amuser
bonsoir mes amis ce soir mes enfants
nous jouons ensemble
colin maillard d'accord c'est très
facile un joueur se met sur les yeux un
tissu plein effet donc ils le voient
plus rien et il doit attraper l'un des
autres joueurs et le reconnaître on le
touche en voilà jobin ce foulard sur
meyzieu comme ça là je le vois plus rien
et maintenant je vais essayer de saisir
la de vous
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez pas si vite tu pas facile
voilà j'en l'ua c'est nicolas j'ai gagné
j'ai reconnu du colloque final c'est à
moi maintenant
oui tiens je te mêles foulard ce que je
joue bien quand même
ce que je suis fort au président non
transparente aux fous là on voit tout à
travers c'est vrai qu'au là-bas tiens
regarde pas preneur tu as triché des
villas vous croyez si annonce va jouer à
colin maillard dommage on va encore
faire appel
colin maillard pêche toi moi la
cherchons maintenant mais nous fait
benoît le tsoup
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous attrapez petit coquin vous
allez voir si je ne suis pas jouer à
colin maillard
ça c'est une bonne force et puis c'est
bien fait il avait quand même pas triché
ouais mais cherchez pas une petite soeur
manu petit frère dors bien
[Musique]
je vais vous attrapez soyez victoire je
retiens rap petit drôle
soit nicolas je gagnais tuquoi de north
ou patrons excusez moi ce n'est rien ou
des petits as mis ton fait une bonne
farce que tu méritais ce brin je la
méritais allons en route
bonne nuit des enfants
[Musique]
oh
allah
[Musique]